it was the day
england fans had waited 55 years for
what's going on
but what should have been a day to
cherish quickly descended into violence
and chaos
wembley stadium was due to be at 75
capacity
sky news estimates that the number of
people who came to wembley
was in the region of 150 000 more than
double its capacity
we've analyzed exactly what happened and
when at the euro 2020 final
it's early afternoon ticket holders and
fans keen to soak up the atmosphere are
starting to arrive on wembley way
hours before the game is due to start
it's getting more and more crowded and
it's clear
thousands of people are arriving without
tickets
for those with tickets there are four
entrances where covert checks and
screenings are taking place
these lead to level one the outer ring
of the stadium
at 5 25 pm the first in a series of
security breaches takes place at one of
the four
entrances at the top of the spanish
steps legitimate ticket holders are
caught up in the crush as the stewards
are overwhelmed
along with at least six police officers
that we have counted in this and other
videos of the scene
shortly after in this video one steward
tries to hold one of the external fences
in place
but there are too many people pushing
through he and his two other colleagues
are quickly overwhelmed
[Music]
we counted at least 50 fans breaking
through running towards the club wembley
entrance
this video filmed from another angle
filmed at 5
37 p.m shows that area with dozens of
people making it into the stadium
grounds
they run up these stairs to level one
where the main axis points directly into
the stadium are
less than 100 meters away on the north
east side of the stadium
oh no a group knocks down a barrier
two mounted police officers move in to
stop others from entering
but there are easier routes for others
at 6 11 pm
at least 10 people climb onto a
temporary toilet block on the south side
by now large numbers of ticklish fans
are inside the grounds
along with others who have paid to be
there and some are about to breach the
inner ring
which leads directly to the seating area
overlooking the pitch
a large crowd attempts to enter at
entrance point g
[Music]
in the first 15 seconds of this clip we
counted at least
50 people entering the stadium
at 7 20 p.m a group attempts to rush a
disabled entrance on the south
east side of the ground a number are
successful
as they overwhelm the four stewards
trying to hold them back
we found two videos of this moment some
other fans already inside attempt to
block
and fight those streaming in the
stewards are overrun
multiple times by the huge numbers
trying to get inside
with minutes to go until kickoff some
fans can be seen pushing out
what appears to be a ticklish fan from
the seating area
[Music]
[Applause]
by the end of the day many fans were
attacked
had their seats taken and were subjected
to abuse
these security breaches led uefa to open
disciplinary proceedings against cfa
they've also dealt a huge blow for the
uk irish bid to host the 2030 world cup
what was supposed to be the dream ending
for many
became a nightmare